وينورنا في الاستوديو البروفيسور يوسف فضل
حسن بروفيسور اهلا بك معنا نورتنا في
الاستديو
على هذه الدعوه القديمه وانا سعيد جدا
بانكون في مدينه الشارقه استرجع وصلتي بها
للنحيه عام 1975
نعم
الثقافيه في الدوره الحاديه والاربعين من
معرض شركه الدولي للكتاب
الجامعيه التي تقدير
معرض كتب له 41 دوله يفرح
والتكريم ياتي من صاحب السمو الشيخ سلطان
بن محمد القاسمي يفرح اكثر
يعني عطائي
ربما هو الاهني لهذه الجائزه طيب حضرتك
وذلك في تاريخ الوسيط للسودان وادي النيل
وطرفيه المهمين تاريخ العربي والتاريخ
الافريقيه
فانا اكاد اكون تخصصت في التاريخ السوداني
وما حدث من تلاقو حلم بين التاريخ العربي
والتاريخ الافريقي جاء نتيجته كبيره من
الجزيره العربيه
في سنه 651 52 ميلادي
واستمر هذا التفاؤل العربي الافريقي
والعربي السوداني وهو ما فضل زميلي
كلها ممالك اسلاميه في السودان وادي النيل
حضرتك وصف كل من التقاك بانك موسوعه في
علوم العرب وعلم افريقيا كيف استقيتم هذه
الموسوعه وحدثنا عن مسارك الحافل في البحث
التاريخ
باللغه العربيه
اجراءات العربيه وكان اول خطوه فعلتها
انقرته كل ما وجدته في جامعه الخرطوم عن
هذا الموضوع ثم دار الكتب المصري
وعندما ذهبت الى اوروبا لجامعه لندن
التحاق طب عدد من الجامعات المهمه في
فرنسا في فينا في
برلين اوكسفور
المصادر الاوليه في تاريخ الاسلام
السعودي
كميه كبيره لا استطيع ان احصلها لك فيديو
اضافه لخزانه الكتب في الدول والمنطقه
العربيه ككل هل واجهتم صعوبات اثناء عملكم
في البحث التاريخي خصوصا معروف انه هناك
صعوبات في عالم الكتابه وعالم البحث
التاريخي الصعوبه
كثيره في الموضوع الذي تبحث عنه ولذلك
لجات لجمع الروايات شفهيه من عن هذا
الموضوع من التراث العربي التراث الافريقي
فكان هذا هو الجديد في بحثه فوق المصادر
العربيه
والافريقيه المكتوبه عن الجا الى الروايه
الشرعيه في ذلك وهذه كثير ايضا
كان كان كانت العون الاساسي
طيب ايه بروفيسور يعني لدي فضول البحث
التاريخي العلمي يتطلب الكثير من الدراسه
من التاني ومن الوقت هل ندمتم على شيء
خلال مصاركم الحافل في البحث العلمي
يعني انا لم تكن عندي هوايه غير البحث ولم
تكون عندي هوايه غير القراءه ولم تكون
عندي القراءه غير مقابله الناس وجمع
الروايات الشفويه فهذه
المطلقه الاساسيه نعم في صعوبه صعوبات
كثيره جدا لكن بطول الزمن والمراد
وخبره تراكميه الوحيده تجاوزه بحمد الله
تاسيس مركز الدراسات الافريقيه في الشارقه
منذ قرابه 50 عاما هل يحقق الاهداف
المطلوبه منه
هذا مركز مهم
اهتمامه الاول
كانت الدعوه
اساسا من صاحب السمو الشيخ سلطان بن محمد
القاسم وهي ليه لتنشيط الحوار العلميين
معرفين بين افريقيا والعالم العربي
دوله الامارات
الاساسيه لجامعه الشارقه مع سمو حكم
الشارقه الشيخ الدكتور محمد القاسمي لو
نقيم مستوى هذه الجامعه مقارنه بجامعه
المنطقه
في وضع بعض الجوانب
وكان كريم جدا في فكره وفي عطائه الجامع
ولذلك قامت على مستوى رفيقي بدات باربع
كليات لكن ما شاء الله الا انت قادتهم
بلغت عشرتك
من هذا الجانب يعني كان يعني بعض المساعده
فيها
يعني هي نموذج طيب للجامعه الحديث
شكرا جزيلا نورتنا هنا